just honored to be mentioned on a legacy
show
like broad city please welcome abby
jacobson
i'm not kidding i would like to thank
you for the cred no
it is my absolute honor we uh
we talked about you all the time in the
writers room it was our pleasure to put
you on the show as much as humanly
possible
yeah i haven't seen that in a second i
miss
doing that now your beautiful partner
the great elana glazer is about to be a
mom
yeah and it's how is that it's it's
incredible
she's been talking about this for a long
time she came over here
um with her partner and they told me
they're so excited she's gonna be such
an incredible mom
she has a lot of like mom
energy already i'm i think uh
she's very motherly um but
it's just been really adorable to see
her belly grow
i'm sorry guys but i'm i wish i should
wish i was just getting choked up but
there was just something in my throat
that i couldn't
but um no like we were in the same city
for a while and now we're not and so i
just get a lot of face times
and pictures of her belly growing but
it's i mean alana's like this
little person anyway it's so cute to
watch her
get bigger well and you are really close
with your mom right
i am yes i'm seeing my mom tomorrow for
mother's day early
i love that you're close with your mom
um what are you guys gonna do
i don't even know i would just hang out
gonna have a dinner in the backyard i
think
with my brother and his kids um i got
her a really cute
shirt and some socks but don't tell her
until she opens it
i won't tell her a thing and now you are
adapting
a league of their own i mean how cool
is this and i heard you actually got to
talk to penny
marshall uh before she
departed this planet with her amazing
gifts that she bestowed upon it
uh it was pretty incredible i mean will
graham asked me to do this project with
him
and we got the opportunity to jump on
the phone with her
really to get her blessing and to just
ask her about the experience
and okay but that's perfect that like
what was penny marshall's blessing what
did it sound like
paint the scene okay perfect she goes
well um go and go and do it already
and go and do it and i was like okay
that was it um yeah she was so sweet
and supportive you know this is
like it's like a it's a very much a
reimagining
of the film we are doing sort of a
re-examining of what it was like
we're telling a lot of stories of what
it was like for women who wanted to
who had the dream to play baseball so
yes it's like a door opens for a lot of
white women and white passing women that
get on the league that we all know from
the film
but what about the black women who were
not allowed to try out
and who had to sort of carve their own
path to play baseball
uh it's also a really queer story
which i know it's wild to imagine that
women playing professional baseball
might have been queer
but they were and that sort of wasn't
part of
the film um so we're really trying to
keep the spirit and the joy that the
film has
and just open up the lens to tell a lot
more stories and a lot more
of the realities of what was really
going on in 1943
okay i have to talk to you um before we
go
about your new film that i'm so
obsessed with the mitchells versus the
machines
i want to tell you one of the reasons
why i love it so much
is because it was one of the first
films that i'm seeing that feels like it
represents what my family is really like
and i just thank you so much for making
this movie
for families out there and i would love
to show
a clip of the mitchells versus the
machines
i just i'm so excited
play it safe when rick mitchell brought
a live
non-neutered feral possum into our home
did he play it safe
no he named him gus and made him a
member of the family
and we all got rabies that one time but
now we're immunized and we're stronger
for it
um abby i'm so honored to uh hang out
with you
the mitchells versus the machines is
available
now on netflix and it's my highest
recommendation for families to get
together
and watch this awesome real humorous
badass adventure that you've made thank
you so much
thank you so much for having me what a
pleasure really
[Music]